still just uh yeah maybe just not
switching gears so okay let's see it's
all about speed we will tell we will be
able to tell a lot over the next ten
moves uh just who can play the quickest
who can go bang bang bang uh with their
moves and
okay d four
uh deep on opening queen's pawn opening
first time we've seen that from magnus
today at least
and okay using this move the move he
used in game six of the world
championship match to win that marathon
battle against the pontiac um this is
really interesting decision making from
magnus and okay black pushing a pawn
white castling this is exactly what we
saw yesterday in one of uh the games
between these two until this last pawn
move really rare decision just backing
up the center with a pawn by magnus i've
never seen this one before in my life
and i've been playing this the whole
time as white pretty much so interesting
decision magnus the first one to make
duda think and dude also backs up his
pawns and do you think our whole idea is
now to start pushing some pawns
challenging black superiority and center
or maybe play a longer game okay well
he's gone for immediate action i like
this i like this idea because you know
black really can't capture the porn
that's been offered up for grabs and
instead decides to capture a pawn in the
middle of the board
and i'm expecting i would say knight
takes born
or is it pawn takes yeah white can
actually has a choice of two pawns to
capture i would maybe capture the pawn
on the fifth rank
because that just opens things up even
quicker it's not clear the pawn that has
just moved where the white wants to take
that with his knight with this pawn uh i
would capture the other one and magnus
did react okay he does go and capture
with the knight uh a bit of discomfort
there seemingly from magnus he didn't
make a quick decision he spent about 20
seconds on that last move and that's not
usual from him in blitz i've played him
hundreds of times in blitz and he's
normally making these decisions
instantly
it feels to me as if magnus is a bit
uncertain and again pausing he's got two
choices he can take back this knight
with the queen or with a pawn he should
have planned this on the last move
instead just taking another 20 seconds
or so and uh
okay still a balanced position but
magnus may be just struggling to switch
into this blitz mode
okay bring out pieces do the castles
very sensible we'll see things speed up
now trade of pawns in the center
dude see how he's reacting instantly to
these big decisions which pieces to
trade magnus doing a much slower version
of that so okay
only bishops now on the board all the
knights have disappeared for blitz i
think both sides will breathe the sigh
of relief the knights are so tricky in
blitz but white has a small advantage
yeah i was going to say more active
queen and something to nibble on on the
left the right side of the ball sorry
the left side of the board
you know and uh white's plan is simple
you know there's one open line and he
wants to put a rook along the sea line
and uh just maximize his forces
and also if you look at the two central
pawns white has an isolated pawn black
has an isolated pawn but white's bishops
are pointing towards those pawns blacks
are purely defending and okay an offer
of a queen trade magnus i'm pretty sure
we'll say no if you trade the queens off
you lose some ammunition for later in
the battle and uh if the queen's come
off i think we'll just see a draw yeah
so magnus needs to keep the queens on
black's queen very passive so don't
trade off an active piece on the side of
the board for a passive one
for me it's tempting just to march the
queen two squares up the board you know
there's a hole there why not just occupy
it yeah that would be very logical you
could also make an argument for just
sliding back on the diagonal one square
is magnus gonna get ambitious with his
queen
he's still playing a bit slowly compared
to dude at least
uh is he still in rapid mode
this is blitz now he needs to decide
he's gonna keep the queens on that's a
given he can't trade them off
unless he's just not feeling it unless
he wants to bring the match to
armageddon well he could also take the
queens off okay he does push the queen
two squares up the board i did wonder
whether maybe he could maybe play a
little bit ambitiously with the queens
off the board but no
i don't think he could and i think
doodle will keep trying to insist on a
queen trade black's queen now blocks up
her rook uh blocks up the top rank so
the queen the black queen could just
slide two squares to the left off a
queen trade very sensible very logical
dude are now pausing but he's got 30
seconds extra on the clock the time
we're going to keep an eye on it because
it's going to decide this game for sure
or it's going to decide the final of the
charity carpent okay playing the most
logical move offering a queen trade
again passive piece for of activities
peace is always a good exchange so
magnus i'm sure he's going to retreat
his queen no way is magnus going to
trade the queens off now
because also that would help blacks
rooks occupy this uh the sea lion the
only open file that ivanka was talking
about
okay white queen has to retreat magnus
has to decide quickly he's a minute down
on the clock yeah if this goes to
armageddon i think duda is the big
favorite because magnus is just not
looking quick right now no he's not
looking confident at all no he's not
it's somehow he
hasn't quite recovered from what
happened in game two
and uh now like you say he's taking his
time it is quite a simple position you
know the pawn structure is almost
well in the middle of the board it's
kind of symmetrical it's pretty clear
not too many minor pieces it's just
about controlling those open files yep
the bishops kind of balance each other
out whites are slightly better than
blacks but it's all about the major
pieces if the rooks will disappear if
the queens disappear dead draw i don't
think black can ever hope to be better
but
it just depends whether white can keep
the rooks on keep the queens on it's not
going to be an easy task
well another great thing about tie
breaks is that we have more time to uh
to get our money for our fundraiser for
unicef youssef from slovakia just
donated 11
um yeah we definitely want to fundraise
more money for the important work unicef
is doing and also a big thank you to all
our um supporting partners all our
participants in the play magnus charity
challenge everyone who has uh
participated in our fundraiser okay we
have a move we have a move and that one
cost duda quite a lot of time and also
it's the most natural move in the
position black's queen now kind of
blocking off white queen from entering
and uh here we go all the rooks looking
at each other challenging
uh for this open sea line white giving
his king some breathing space black is
likely to do the same
uh the black king okay there we go duda
you don't want to leave your king with
no breathing space especially in blitz
there'll be all sorts of tricks against
your king all these background
checkmates and is it a good idea okay
well he's actually improved the bishop
you know put it in the middle of the
board
[Music]
i i mean it just feels like a move a
nice move but uh okay and duda kicking
away the queen and i was curious as to
whether you know this was actually a
good plan by duda because it does mean
that the contact point between white's
army and the black army has suddenly
drawn closer and there you can see
magnus just uh breaking through on the
left side and dude a tiny almost
imperceptible shake of his head there um
he's not so happy suddenly this is a
magnus type of position again
white has a small advantage because of
his superior bishops and white holds the
key to the queen side ivanka you looked
surprised for a second yeah and i was
just wondering whether the bishop that
uh at the minute was looking at not too
many pawns could actually step back and
start targeting the weak pawn that is
going to appear on b5 yep so white's
light squared bishop in front of his
king it's a bit redundant right now no
real work for it just staring at a
well-defended pawn so ivanka is
expecting it to drop back in a moment
but first big decision queen trade
can i avoid this dude really trying to
insist uh throughout this middle game on
getting the queens off uh endgames
usually favor magnus but the problem is
there are no knights no real imbalances
if the queen's come off i fear we're
headed towards a draw so can magnus keep
the queens on it's not easy maybe the
white queen can just slide back to the
left just to the a2 square keep yourself
nice and safe avoiding any traits and
then your banker's idea of dropping
white's light squared bishop back
hitting the black queen
on a different diagonal so
okay magnus still hesitant
yes we'll move 23 okay he trades a set
of rooks first we'll move 23 24 but
down to two minutes for both sides i
think if these two just played a blitz
game without having played the kind of
rapid play games earlier today they
would have been much quicker than this
and we've seen a trade of queens
actually
and uh well he did uh re-maneuver his
light square bishop to attack the pawn
so now duda has to deal with that either
he defends or he goes on the counter
attack and he pushes forward with the
pawn magnus quickly moving the bishop to
cover the key c2 square very nice move
there from magnus stopping the black
rook from ever intruding into white's
half of the board now all of black's
squares for his rook are controlled on
the c line or white has full control
there but white's rook cannot be
controlled by black's pieces so white's
root can jump in and be get active at
any moment it's not easy for black to do
the same okay dude fighting for space on
the other flank
in the opening middle game this would
have been very very weakening the black
king would be very open but queens have
disappeared so this is fine it totally
feels like like this weakening though i
think it's fine i think dude had to try
this at some point because otherwise he
would have been uh suffocated almost for
space we had some pre-moves yeah some
pre-moves and white capturing a porn
duda had assumed that white would
capture it so he took back with his own
pawn instantly he'd made that move
happen before it even uh occurred on the
board and look at this the rook coming
in
yeah maybe you'll be proved right ivanka
maybe the black king will be the target
it feels like magnus is trying to
somehow break his rook across the board
if you can pick up the white rook and
plant it next to the black king on the
h8 square that's actually checkmate so
maybe magnus is just trying to plot a
path for that white rook
meanwhile the black rock has to guard
the eighth rank now just to prevent any
checkmates and the white king freita
free to wander yeah white's king is very
very safe no attacking pieces around it
and actually this is the key move for
magnus i was underestimating maybe the
threats against black's king because i
thought black could pick up the f pawn
and kick away white's bishop from the
center of the board but that's not
possible white's rook is actually eyeing
up black's light squared bishop so uh
yeah black's a bit frozen black's a bit
stuck
not clear what to do and
despite uh me mentioning it was a bit
slow from both sides earlier magnus is
sped up he's quickened the pace
and i think he's made the last five or
six moves and only spent 10 seconds
doing that
so uh duda under one minute for the
first time
can he react this is again not a duda
type of position he very rarely thrives
in these types of
kind of drier end games where he's
purely defending
and okay he locks down the pawn
structure on the right side of the board
but that's committal as well yeah i
think he primarily did that to release
the dark square bishop because that one
the dark square bishop was kind of stuck
on its square and now the king joins in
the action
and uh it's time for white's king as
well to do the same
so magnus just keeping his king nice and
safe black's rook just hinting at
getting active it wants to bring itself
down maybe to the second rank to go for
some white pawns but you've got to be
really careful if the black rook ever
moves white's rook is going to go to the
eighth rank with a deadly check
so okay magnus keeping black's king
honest keeping black's king tied down to
one of its bishops
and duda trying to evict this white rook
this one's still very tense it feels
like magnus is making progress but you
still need some tangible you need to win
a pawn or you need something in order to
win this game
dude just going back and forth just
trying to just fix the blockade
maybe it's time just to improve the king
get the king into the action put it in
the center
and see maybe whether the king can kind
of snake its way around and i'm thinking
of putting it on the b3 square yeah
white's king not really doing too much
where it previously stood so ivanka's
plan of marching the white king all the
way across the board black's doing the
same black's playing copycat the black
king's coming the white king is coming
who's king is going to
be better placed it feels like white's
king has the easier path white's king
can easily slide across black's king if
it moves too close to the okay he's got
to be careful if it moves too close to
the white rook might walk into some
deadly checks and duda 28 seconds left
is magnus playing for the win here
definitely and you can see the king is
coming and it wants to sit on the b3
square and once it's blockading the pawn
then that pawn is a target and this is
why duda just decides no he does not
want that king on the b3 square and
instead cuts it off yeah look at black's
pieces they're all kind of bunched
together right in the center but they're
passive black's light squared bishop
can't move you might lose some pawns
black's dark square bishop can't move
you might lose some points black's rook
now forced to cut off the white king
what is black gonna do
nearly everything he touches might have
uh kind of bad consequences right now
yeah he just has to wait with his king i
mean there's not too many okay so he
moves his rook now your plan your anchor
the white king can continue its journey
towards the left yeah and uh yeah dude
shaking his head as well 15 seconds
happy not happy but now magnus under a
minute on the clock and he has to take a
decision yeah and uh is he going to move
that white king he does he does very
natural it's the continuation of a
consistent plan very important in every
end game being consistent and okay duder
trying to maybe hint at trapping the
white rook also setting a nasty idea of
checkmate if the white king continues
its journey and goes to the b3 square
but magnus says no now a trade of light
squared bishops would favor magnus
because if black captures this bishop
white will just retrieve the rook and
take a pawn dude oh he played that move
with just five six seconds left and the
black king is coming
wow duder trying to trap the white rook
really sneaky plan there
but uh okay now the black rock gets
active at least and has magnus lost
control yeah the bar is down to zero he
has 35 seconds left on the clock
and well this is why the magnus has
utilized the dark square bishop just to
control and protect those pawns on the
right dude i'm miraculously just
unraveling and that black rook is super
active now also this is really
reminiscent this endgame of duda's win
against magnus carlsen in the world cup
last year that one was also a dark
square bishop end game where black's
pawns were better than white's pawns
black's rook was more active than
white's rook so magnus has to be careful
not to lose control duda has beaten him
in this type of position you know i
think the game is actually soon going to
finish in a draw because i don't think
magnus has a good answer to the rook
shuffling between the e1 square and the
d1 square
yeah so white's king now under check if
you go to the right
you would have walked into black's rook
going to the left if you went to the
left you would have walked into a
black's root going the other way uh so
right now a bit of tension and black's
rook just keeping attacking pawns and
magnus leans back he knows as ivanka
says this game is destined to be a draw
no way to escape the checks no ways to
escape blacks rooks threats okay and
there's a big threat in the air and
that's to play bishop takes pawn
destabilizing the protection of the
light dark square bishop while magnus
plays for the win he didn't want the
draw there which would have been the
safe option duda under 60
he made that move with two seconds left
dude shaking his head now magnus can go
and grab a pawn in the center with the
white rook
wow okay magnus is attacked the black
rook is magnus winning material oh look
at that the bar goes up magnus trick
duder there he's attacking the black
rook the black freak is about to fall
the black bishop under a threat as well
white is winning a piece here now you
can just take this black rook swing the
white rook over and
magnus takes the win duda blunded
in time horribly game over minus carlsen
with the white pieces the winner of the
first blitz game he is up by one point
both players